welcome welcome to this video playing
swap from Germany there's no master
Miller I've got tons of games against in
15 games and I don't have a good score
just plus one seems pretty a check
pretty weak score okay so we have some
sort of English reti opening and i
really i really don't know them the
precise way to play that i never thought
that this should give white anything
much but at least that I could play some
some quick moves aha yeah it's not a
position where you can do very much it's
a very compact very compact set up the
only a slight thing is that maybe I can
do something against the c5 pawn but
it's not quite apparent how this should
lead to anything serious yar nice to be
4i maybe okay let's let's cover the
square right before at least would allow
him some sort of firm perpetual I mean
at least I'm not saying he Sam he is
forced to do that or anything black is
definitely okay
I can maybe just play a form I go if I
can at least play night before night to
d5 back all the time we are a form
now I don't really like that very much
but who came let's let seem at least
after the caption no chase I'm putting
some pressure on this on this pawn on c5
but hmm it's not very good this is not
very good not like us definitely more
than okay here maybe a move like yeah
something like that Knight b6 comes into
consideration where you can maybe park
the noite ranae for which is quite nice
running right into Queen g5 maybe
yeah I really didn't have a good idea
here now that's really annoying maybe I
can yeah we'll take take take and then
c4 and then a three hangs at the end of
all of it bull that's not good
yeah I noticed that this move is this
really a really uncomfortable but just
just too late I really don't see him a
good move here
yeah c'mon let's at least get rid of the
coins am in this kind of structure the
b5 pawn will also be a weakness so it
shouldn't be shouldn't be terribly bad
okay so rugby one rugae 3 i'm not able
to take that's bad news so I probably
have to do this possibly would be three
like rugby a droopy three
if you try it's bishop takes I'm
directly attacking c7 Archie can maybe
just move this yeah
yep he can just move it ok maybe here I
can go to d5 now you can do to d5 which
is not helping me a lot 193 back yeah
it's not nice but maybe still oh yes I
didn't expect I thought that this should
be ok for me I have 94 to a taxi five so
the d3 porn is not not a big issue i
thought and i have an active rock song
I can just take that you can just take
this night this was this was ridiculous
I mean I'm also taking c7 but you can
just take it I I have completely i will
loop that maybe I also time more didn't
react to it weird yeah but what exactly
is a can I do anything with that not
really am now it was very weird maybe i
can drop back and then play in rugae
seven
this night is not have any squares yes
yes yes that's true that's true but I
have this have this Bishop a three trick
I with the rocking game
now you can promote and take on f2 which
is pretty easy that's a fancy way to do
it gather was a bad game now right out
of the opening I had a wrong position at
least the passive position like four
things on time dad was a lousy game
really I mean around here I probably a
yeah I don't know maybe I should lose
anymore or something but it just was
just just not yeah this is just bad of
course but you can go to d5 and still
I'm worse yeah I'm out of the woods
basically I just need to play good moves
which I fail to 294 probably one might
be three some counter-attack should that
should be ok but it was a very
unattractive position the whole way
something like that yes probably
probably right with with the draw coming
but that's really ridiculous I
completely overlooked that the night is
hanging and you can just take it if he
wants this is just good this is just
good for for public in something like
this
pretty obviously but yeah here I really
don't have a good reply to that as well
I mean Roxy to was wasn't wasn't helping
us were strong and here well yeah he
simply wouldn't wouldn't make any any
mistake here yeah i played this opening
very quickly i mean this is a known
setup but also set up that's not giving
white anything so maybe i should have
thought a little bit here to to get a
position that i really like to play this
i I really don't don't like very much
it's just a bit of a yeah you can you
can basically just sit around here don't
do anything yeah Jim yeah I mean okay
the thing is also of course I can do
this but I didn't want that because it
allows a direct draw which you I mean
what kind of video is that and it's
clear that this is strategically the
right move because while he he he's also
almost obliged to make this drum I mean
he cannot do that this is just good for
white I mean giving me the backward porn
and so on so he basically yeah so this
is the real point I should should make
this draw but I didn't really consider
that seriously as it is a game on video
and so on it's not very attractive that
you want to do something with white and
here I'm just I'm just worse yeah this
is kind of structure yeah Queen a 2 was
also stupid move yeah but if you look at
this I mean this is just good for black
he's got this response its base
advantage and I really don't have any
plans of just a very unattractive
position okay thanks for watching